yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing pan Opticon now for the 8 games
we have select I wouldn't have thought
it is such a frequent opponent okay he
goes for the varnish variation look see
one that we should have 5 so let's see
what he does I recently made a move on a
slip played 96 here this is funny this
is exactly what I got in a tournament
game just just a month ago maybe this is
my opponent and he now has a C from
France and he now has some kind of
improved window so that would be funny
ok so he took here my opponent in France
played d5 so with this one the answers
an interesting choice and normally you
would take with the pawn but Knight
takes make some sense IAM as everything
is loose and bishop c6 looks like
strombel yeah I think I'll go with
Knight takes pawn takes always has this
94 idea but yeah I mean why this really
am yeah playing this super ambitiously
and has weakened themself a lot now we
have to move the rook clear f3 that's
nine takes d4 Knight f3 blunders g4 so
he more or less has to go
book h2 or h3 and now so we will
probably see Queen d2 this is something
that that needs to be taken seriously
it's not completely bonkers
22 is probably his next move
can I do something that makes this more
difficult Queen to d7 maybe it also
connects looks something to d5 I can
always just capture this is okay in
something to e5 Knight to d5 let's be
precise what I didn't really think of
policy has got f4 here and then I have
no square for my knight what what am I
doing here I simply didn't think about
f4 this is probably right because why is
taking some time contemplating what my
big ideas against therefore I don't have
an idea I mean if the position is so
opened up then maybe I can get some
swindling type of compensation but I did
not really I didn't see it I just didn't
see it completely forgot about that my
knight has no squares and
yeah fantastic
so what am i doing
you create and then play on the evil or
something
yeah what'd I miss
should be to now is a threat I think the
book has almost no squares yeah takes
first my F takes weakens this diagonal
it's also not good oh my god
I'd already believe and watch position
before I bluntly the piece it is such a
loose position with the King in the
middle and everything but okay if you
learn the piece you can play lots of
things against a meal
it's still not easy for white which
makes pretty clear how and how
problematic the position was before I've
learned that everything so what to do
d5 can check there may be here for Queen
f6 I don't know neither f3 I can no
cannot take this maybe Bishop g3 or
something taking on c3 ebooks III Class
III yeah with what do I take this
probably
okay 93 looks normal
I was thinking we should be - I really
can't even play we should deform
probably
and of Marcel I can do should deform it
maybe I should have a voice it I mean
it's clear that this wins now when I
take with the rook can I do some sweet
ling stuff yes the take with a king then
time warning check
yeah it's not exactly difficult okay
plundering for peace down below the
boredom
I'm Luke Tanya black rewind there was an
extremely extremely stupid loss in the
position where white has I think
enormously overextended I mean maybe the
engine disagrees that's really possible
you never know already in those wild
positions but I don't believe in this
stuff so the engine gives roughly equal
gases it's just a joke game I've landed
the big piece in the middle of the board
they are so nucleate or something is
some is equal according to the computer
now in an extremely wild position where
everything anything my tap from knowing
this is just I just didn't see it when
this is F for would be entirely
ridiculous unless it wins a p7 it wins
apiece so I didn't didn't anticipate a
foil or sometimes a problem that I have
and I tend to look for like logical
moves in a way I like you shift in
develop this night on g1 how can you do
that blah blah blah this is of course
irrelevant because it plays that Freud
wins apiece so yeah now here I'm just a
piece down for nothing at all yeah yeah
we should take four strong okay yeah
okay
simply blundering a piece is not good
yeah yeah you can take with a pawn I
don't know both look look okay Knight
takes I think it's more logical and I'm
okay with all that and this is just
stupid didn't didn't consider for okay
guys thanks for watching